the direction here looks really solid it
seems to have a lot of themes about
embracing yourself deeper understanding
of music learning to being the moment
there's so much here learning to love
your nose
and the music industry has told me that
my nose is too big and that I won't make
it learning to love your nose which
ironically is something I have really
struggled with in my life I've had
problems with my nose I have yeah yeah
got a beautiful nose now you know I
don't believe you're full of [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm fine I take it back full of
[ __ ] you want to touch it
no what come on man bringing down my
lips hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba
what's your name good sir man I wish I
was prepared my name is Andrew Hayes
Andrew Hayes from the YouTube channel
Andrew Hayes guys go check out his
reviews channel you might have heard us
mention it a few times he has been a
longtime follower of our channel and
he's been a longtime
fellow patron objective do you like our
patreon of course they're not paying me
to say this
no he's paying us we've done many Google
Hangouts in today's the first day we're
actually meeting each other yes in
person he is a lot taller than I
expected I feed exact Wow good for you
you were like a star in the make its
transition a star is born people I find
this story pretty funny I've been seeing
a lot on Twitter of people complaining
about this apparently Warner Brothers
put out these for like one minute and a
half TV spots before the nun they're
playing all four B's that's an
interesting thing and people are really
complaining going it doesn't fit what I
what I found funny was when I saw black
Klansmen there were a lot of movie
trailers and the theme of black lives
matter and
in the middle of all that they played
the trailer first star just like the
widest movie yeah so they have these
four out and I'm like we gotta check
this out cuz I gotta see what everyone's
complaining about funny enough though
this movie is actually getting amazing
reviews yeah I'm really happy for
Bradley Cooper cuz it's a directorial
debut Lady Gaga I think is amazing her
work on American Horror Story I think
it's great I'm happy that this film is
doing well there's a there's a lot of
pressure on this film to do well and
yeah it's the third or fourth one - so
the fourth one yeah you know when you're
this far into remakes you gotta make a
good one let's start checking these out
before we're gonna check out our 12
notes a way out songwriter and one
reason in that order
I'm correcting myself okay cool I am
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah yeah oh damn you depressed it's a
trailer song
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it feels like a documentary concert yeah
any of you repeat the same story she is
beautiful yeah clap Bradley Cooper was
able to tell her that Yuri I felt like
this trailer was talking to us it was
like a minute minute review for every
one of these like this trailer was
talking to us you know talking about how
the 12 notes Sam Elliott tastes like
it's the same story told over and over
I'm like yeah god I'm like a stars board
trailers doing yeah maybe they're gonna
just make these until there's 12 stars
and even with Bradley Cooper looking
kind of at the camera at the end asking
or you already it seemed like this
trailer is directed at us to set us up
for the 4-3 big yeah I do like the kind
of documentary concert vibe you know
when you see those a band on tour and
stuff
I like that vibe that we were getting in
this one yeah I mean you could tell how
much emotions oh yeah this alone like
Bradley Cooper brings to this like it
seems like there's something going on
with it
yeah and this movie has great reviews
and it seems like it paid off that for
Bradley Cooper to recognize how cool he
thinks he is so much cooler than me so I
can make that joke that you got to
respect the beard respect hey let's
watch this next one it's call the way
out Dave Chappelle's in this first image
as we can see that's why they played
this before black Klansmen yeah and
peels too
everybody primarily white people like
country music
yeah primarily white people you think we
do it so soon man come on bro you know
damages artists didn't know that was a
person you know there's something about
when we started playing I always knew
like you were gonna do something that
you'd be alright it's the first time I
worried about you
[Music]
and this looks depressing she's she's
aware you know it's like
I know you
you float out
so what I see you then one day you find
a port and we stay here for a few days
few days it comes a few years
[Music]
we forgot we were going in the first
place you realize you really give a [ __ ]
about we was going because you like we
yeah ha
[Music]
something tells me that's like the
themes of the movie yeah disclaimer him
and I have never seen any of a star is
born' movies I don't really know where
this takes place in the where this
speech takes place at the time line it
looks like their relationship has fallen
apart and Bradley Cooper is really
depressed yes and kind of felt like a
spoiler to me or maybe this is one of
those things where the scene is really
early on in the movie then they cut they
cut back to the past and we watched the
movie unfold because he's saying all
these things in it that is showing this
imagery of love and I'm getting along
and you know this was really unexpected
and they thought they might just hang
out for a while but then ended up being
this really long time now looks like his
world has fallen apart a Dave Chappelle
has to pick him up I don't know if this
was like a spoilery moment if this is
like the all's lost moment of the movie
he's has to rediscover himself something
that I'm curious about it seems that
he's an alcoholic it has an alcohol
problem yeah and I made which is an
alcoholic well I think there's a
difference between alcoholic and
drinking problem was what I was thinking
of we can argue this semantics all
alcoholic and maybe maybe there has a
something to do with why his
relationship with Lady Gaga's character
fell apart or maybe why is relationship
with Dave Chappelle's character fell
apart and has a big reason to why he is
the way he is and why he is as depressed
as he is and yeah I gotta say to Dave
Chappelle it's only like 40 seconds if
you have given a rather dramatic talk
not once was I thinking at all funny man
Dave Chappelle doing something serious
[ __ ] are so sensitive the whole
country is turned into [ __ ] he
was very believable
yeah very believable that delivery so
was Bradley Cooper just sitting that and
yeah he does a great job at sitting he's
a good listener though he's a great job
but just looking down at this yeah I'm
wondering when this moment is gonna take
place in the movie it seems like their
relationship is gonna blossom at first
and then it's gonna fall apart
especially based off the second clip
that we got here terms of Dave
Chappelle's acting I'm looking forward
to seeing more of his performance
because that was very believable maybe
maybe this is all that Dave Chappelle's
hood maybe this is the only scene he has
it's just a can
let's find out hey there's another one
all four of these plays before the nun
go watch the nun this weekend people
definitely seems like no wonder everyone
is so happy about these clips playing
because it fits for the audience that is
watching the nun songwriters as one
[Music]
[Music]
colleague did me see these really dead
now yeah good I started writing this
song the other day maybe not gonna work
because of chorus or something
[Music]
[Music]
tell your secret don't worry I won't
tell anybody
but I'm not very good at keeping secrets
never gave me some like actual chills
though yeah yeah that's the song I think
that one of the sons that plays the
actual train I think it's like when she
goes up yeah when he/she lagana want him
and she sings it that's kind of cool you
get to see what makes that song yeah and
probably what's gonna make that moment
in the movie yeah and very like cool to
see cuz you know in the trailer you hear
all them but like and this is just the
vocals and it's very very wrong you get
the emotion yeah especially with clips
that they were playing like behind it
like with her singing is very emotional
every clip we've seen of this so far
today has such a melancholy like
depressing yeah the treads make it seem
like it's sort of like a happy again
like an inspiring tale like watching
these like a really sad yeah I mean you
can tell like Bradley Cooper has a
drinking problem it's gonna be some like
painful moments kind of like a biopic
like I go ah but he's he's gonna get
through it in the end I'm gonna get
through it
yeah everyone who'd seen he just look so
sad yeah even the first one that's 12
notes when he before replays he looks
like he doesn't want to be on stage you
know yeah I don't know if that's before
or after he knows Lady Gaga's cared it
seems like that he's probably a
depressed guy with the and anybody's
doing the music and everything and he
probably feels this sort of like
reinvigoration when he meets Lady gaga
yeah
I'm getting from here but let's watch
the last one this one's the most viewed
one it's called one reason can I ask you
a personal question
do you write songs or anything I don't
sing songs why I just I just don't feel
comfortable I want you feel confident
well cuz like almost every single person
that I've come in contact with in the
music industry has told me that my nose
is too big and that I won't make it your
nose beautiful are you showing me your
nose I know you know can I touch your
name
[Music]
it's a very sexual way oh yeah not
really my nose has not made lucky look
talent comes everywhere but having
something to say no way to say it so
people listen to it that's a whole other
bag unless you get out there and you try
to do it you'll never know that's just
the truth if there's one reason we're
supposed to be here is to say something
so people want to hear you gotta grab it
and you don't want colleges you don't
worry about why they're listening or how
long they're gonna be listening for you
just tell them what you want to say
don't you understand I'm trying to tell
you that's my favorite
hey that one actually wasn't that like
said no probably very early on in the
movie we're gonna get that scene and I
imagine the other scenes that we watched
all the sad stuff range of emotion we're
gonna get with the Jobi because the
three beavers ones they were very very
sad this one it was very funny he liked
just the way he like acted goes on I
like it goes like yeah I've done that
with many girls and I've been arrested
many their chemistry yes like really
dynamite man that scene alone sold me on
the romance and yeah like the other
stuff looked good but this seems to
specifically when they're meeting is a
beautiful chemistry I just love it at
the end where she goes I understand but
I don't like it yeah that was pretty
pretty good I wonder if that whole
comments about her nose I wonder if
that's a real thing Lady Gaga has had to
go through about her nose and they
borrow it's for racial you're talking
about that and they included it in this
I know Lady Gaga has talked about before
like she has had people come out there
and be like alright we like your music
but we just don't want you singing it
let's buy your music and you know okay
he was just like no so they cast her cuz
of like real things she's had two
variants interesting that whole thing
about the nose is so specific and it
doesn't look like she's wearing a
prosthetic no is it for them to talk
about it I'm wondering was this like a
real thing real issue she wants dealt
with very early on and I don't think
they were just like included asked her
maybe she says hey listen like they made
fun of my eyes maybe that's her
character art she learns to love her
nose by the end of the movie yeah maybe
this is just a lady Gaga biopic is a
lady Gaga biopic about her learning to
embrace her facial features
it's not about Bradley Cooper at all
he's like in it for like two seconds no
she's the star that's being born right
now it's actually starts with her mother
giving birth to her
why a star is born interesting that's
why it's really dark again it's actually
actually you think it's the real thing
like oh yeah watch this in the right
order I feel yes so if you're gonna do
it do it like that do it like that yeah
don't watch it before you watch the non
hopefully yeah just because it's Warner
Brothers does not mean it's the same
crowd but I'm looking forward to this
movie it's getting great feedback I
haven't read the details other young
people are really loving the movie
anyway
starters Bourne comes out soon people
over October something just the time you
want to watch it you guys can subscribe
to the reject nation and click that
notification Belka subscribe button suck
and hey check out Andrew Hayes on the
youtubes people Andrew Hayes is a great
movie review channel we're all expecting
a star is born' review don't worry just
just for you guys nobody else appreciate
that Andrew hey check us out on patreon
we got full-length TV show reactions
Andrew doesn't watch any of those weekly
Q&A s he watches one of them we just
mine just the one where my answer is
bunch of other [ __ ] go check it out -
worth your time maybe